where Emperors
Reign and Gladiators
entertain sight of luxury excess and the
everpresent danger of the
M for five centuries Rome dominates the
Western world but the real secret of the
Empire's power lies elsewhere beneath
the Seas it once
commanded without the sea and without
controlling the Trad rits of the sea
there would have been no
Empire imagine if we could empty the
oceans letting the water drain away to
reveal the secrets of the seaf
Flor now we can using accurate data and
astonishing technology to bring light
once again to a lost
world
how does a mysterious Lake miles from
the city explain Rome's Mastery of the
Mediterranean it was built on a scale
unlike anything else only the Roman
emperors were this ambitious what can a
maritime graveyard Unearthed in an
Italian field tell us of Rome's one
great
weakness and how does a lost Marvel on a
distant medit anean Shore explain Rome's
greatest ever feat of engineering the
Romans took technology to a whole
another
level when the Great historian Livy sets
out to write the story of his City
he knows it all comes down to
location Gods and Men together chose
this
place Hills with pure
air a convenient
River a sea handy for our
needs all these advantages marked us out
for Glory
Rome is the world's first
superpower but it doesn't start that
way over the course of 500 years it
grows from a fortified settlement to a
powerful Republic and finally an Empire
demanding the allegiance of over 16
million people from Britain in the north
down the coast of Africa and into the
Middle East
East Rome's power rests on the unrivaled
might of its
Army and Engineering skills that
astonish its Rivals but that's not all
so everyone thinks they know the story
of the Roman Empire and it's a story of
of Legions and of roads and of building
massive
structures but the key really was
control of the
sea controlling the sea is essential
because Rome struggles to feed its
[Music]
people by the first century ad the
population of the capital swells to 1
million the largest city the world has
ever
[Music]
seen and if those people go
hungry they
Riot well Rome is dependent on obtaining
about 150 to 300 million tons of grain
annually to keep the population
fed if you were an emperor you wanted to
be seen as someone who was providing for
the population so really without that
grain coming in they couldn't hold on to
power how the Emperors managed this has
long puzzled
historians but now buried underground
and Miles Inland an extraordinary
Discovery could unlock lock the
mystery Rome's challenge isn't shipping
grain from the
Empire it's getting it to the city
itself 15 miles from the
sea there must have been a huge Port
somewhere on the coast or Inland up the
river
Tyber but its whereabouts are a mystery
today International Teams are trying to
piece together the puzzle of the Lost
Port archaeologist Peter Campbell is
determined to discover how Rome handled
its biggest problem feeding nearly a
million people would have been an
incredible task to the ability to get
that material from around the
Mediterranean up to the city took just
an incredible amount of human willpower
and
[Music]
labor you need Anchorage space you need
Harbor
facilities Simon K leads a group of
experts who are studying the Lost
Port you need the infrastructure to
support them and you need the
administrative framework um indeed to
enable them to
function Clues first Unearthed over a
century ago are tantalizing the early
sources are very very
important they saw things they recorded
them historical texts refer to a port
without equal somewhere on the coast
near the mouth of the
Tyber established by the emperor
Claudius by 46
ad and extended by the emperor Tran over
60 years
later
the Romans call it pis a single carved
relief dating from the late 2nd Century
ad hints at its
magnificence but gives no sense of its
true scale or how it
[Music]
worked other sources speak of a
hexagonal Basin at the center of a vast
complex called the port ttis
triani could evidence of it still
survive 2,000 years
[Music]
later Simon is convinced that it does
about 15 miles south of Rome where he's
come to investigate strange ruins and a
mysterious
Lake it has six clearly defined sites
and looks
man-made
it covers almost 880 Acres as large as
13 Roman coliseums joined together but
there's a
problem it's 2 miles from the
Mediterranean
Coast could the heart of the legendary
porise lie so far
inland and where is the rest of it so
little is known about the layout of the
ancient
Port it's very very hard to understand
how it all fits
[Music]
together archaeologists survey close to
the lake through here then you just get
into different phases running down
through
there probing beneath the surface for
any
evidence about me m and a half I say for
met to start hitting the water table
[Music]
combining discoveries made here during
past construction
work and these new archaeological
investigations it's now possible to
produce a new window into the
past the mud and silt of 2,000 years
drains
away and 6 ft below the
surface buried archaeological
treasure The Remains Not of a
port but something that might have used
it a
boat from this field 2 miles from the
coast four other vessels emerge into the
light it's an extraordinary discovery
[Music]
the archaeologists pour over the
evidence and realize they are some of
the most complete Roman vessels ever
discovered it's even possible to date
one of
them based on the construction features
we can estimate that it dates the 2
Century
ad in the second century the Roman
Empire Empire is at its
height if it ever needed a truly Grand
Port this is the
moment but if these beautifully
preserved boats used this
port why are they so far
inland Peter Campbell finds more
[Music]
evidence not far from The Wooden Boats
the remains of what looks like a long
low
wall and it's definitely
[Music]
Roman more surveys reveal this is just
one section of an early 6,000 ft long
structure now mostly hidden beneath the
ground further archaeological work
unearths a second wall curling back
towards the
first and deposits on the walls give a
further
clue if you walk along this structure
you can actually see calcium deposits at
a certain level and it creates this
white line along the length of it and
those are actually marine
concretions marine concretions are
sediments that cling to structures at
seawater level leaving a white
mark this whole area close to the
hexagonal Basin was once
underwater it's another astonishing
find in Roman days this is where the
coast was and the curving structures
make up a huge protective
Harbor this must be pis
but one big question
remains the city is 15 M further
Inland connected to the Sea by the river
Tyber and the mouth of the river is
nearly 2 miles from
pis so how did food ever get to
Rome
[Music]
the architects who designed pis faced
one key challenge feeding Rome's million
strong
population so how does the harbor
connect to the city 15 M
away moving huge volumes of cargo by
existing roads would have been
costly and the most obvious route to
Rome the river Tyber is too shallow for
merchant
[Music]
vessels studying the ancient boats dug
up
nearby Peter Campbell finds an important
clue rather than having a v-shape as you
would have with a seagoing ship this
actually has a relatively flat bottom
which would have allowed it to travel in
much shallower Waters it was used within
the harbor and up the
Tyber this vessel is an important piece
of the puzzle in the network that
connected the ocean to the
city the harbor lies more than a mile
from the banks of the
Tyber How could a cargo carrying vessel
reach the
river Peter consults the archaeological
surveys and spots a set of parallel
lines near the hexagonal basis
they look like the remains of a man-made
channel the data reveal a major canal
system connected poris Harbor to the
Tyber an astonishing feat of Roman
engineering if you look at the landscape
of the River today there's the main
channel that we're in right now
but in the past there would have been
multiple other canals and we've only
recently discovered those others uh
through
geoarchaeology the archaeologists Now
understand the full scale of the poris
complex and how it connects to
Rome but there is still a
mystery at the heart of the port beyond
the vast main Harbor lies the huge
enclosed hexagonal basin
apparently unique in the ancient
world but what was it
for today from the surface it seems like
an ordinary
Lake but by using the latest computer
visualization
techniques we can look
deeper as the water seeps away it
exposes not the muddy Bank of a natural
lake but a crumbling brick
wall similar walls support the other
sides of the
hexagon and then something
startling a white block with a hole
through the
center one of dozens protruding from the
brick
work close by the remains of a
column and just visible on it Roman
symbols for the number
[Music]
23 can ruins scattered nearby help
reveal the hexagon's
purpose Simon K thinks
so to his expert eye they are Roman and
important
we're currently standing in one of the
largest surviving buildings from pter
the thick walls large enclosed space and
a wide opening all point to one
thing these are
warehouses warehouses designed to store
the most important commodity in the
Roman Empire grain for the people of
Rome they are the largest place of grain
storage in the whole pis complex
[Music]
making them the largest grain warehouses
in the Roman
Empire it's now clear what the drained
hexagonal lake is
for moing rings for ships to unload a
broad keyside surrounding the
lake and the numbered column docking
station one of dozens in the whole
complex
the hexagon is the heart of
pis a purpose-built facility to manage
dozens of cargo ships at a
time Decades of archaeological work
haven't simply found some ancient docks
and
warehouses they've uncovered the secret
to the success of Rome itself allowing
us to understand exactly how the
Emperors fed a million
people now for the first time in almost
two Millennia the true scale and
Brilliance of pis is revealed in
full approaching ships arrive at the
outer
harbor some more
here others head further into the
port to dock at numbered moing
Rings The Great Basin can hold over a
vessels surrounding them another
engineering Marvel and a hint of the
Majesty of
Rome not only warehouses and harbor
offices but giant temples and statues
too the sheer volume of goods passing
through ptis is beyond anything the
world has ever
seen while a host of smaller barges wait
to Ferry cargo through the canals to the
river Tyber and onto
Rome the hexagonal Basin at pis is the
final crucial Link in the supply chain
from the Empire to Rome
itself the ultimate symbol of Rome's
Mastery of the
seas in pis we're seeing the Roman
Empire at its height we're seeing the
first and 2 centuri ad they're building
a massive port and it's the most
advanced it's the most Monumental it's
the most spectacular port and it's
actually making a statement about
Rome vessels from across the empire
Empire flock to this engineering
Marvel can the surprising cargo of one
ship destined for pis explain how Rome
survives one of its greatest ever
[Music]
disasters the Mediterranean Super
Highway of the Roman
Empire for five centuries it's
crisscrossed by Merchant
ships many carrying grain to
pis very few have ever been
found but off the coast of Spain near
the city of Alicante an ancient
shipwreck is discovered by two amateur
divers Jose Bo and Antoine
ferer Maritime archaeologists name it
after them the B
fer when Carlos Dean hears about it he
sets out to discover
[Music]
more we have some evidence of a seere
from Roman period uh right underneath
where we are right
[Music]
now it is absolutely emotional emotional
moment
and I felt that it was the beginning of
[Music]
something 80 ft below the
surface something rare and
precious the bones of the B farer and
the remains of her
cargo Carlos thinks it's Roman but is he
right and what was she
[Music]
carrying the Mediterranean
empties and light pours once again onto
this ancient and mysterious
ship spread across the seafloor a
mountain of amfor
many completely intact despite lying at
the bottom of the Mediterranean for many
centuries the storage jars are used to
carry food oil and wine in the ancient
world clear evidence that this is a
Roman
wreck the sheer number of amfor suggests
she was an unus usually large cargo
ship but little of her frame
remains just a few Timbers from the hull
have survived the ravages of
time it is a great opportunity for the
archaeology to learn more about the
those big vessel those Merchant vessel
of Roman
period the fully drained remains reveal
a shape that's typical of a Roman
merchant
ship but much bigger than
most pulling her skeleton together from
the Bottom of the Sea we can recreate
the bow forer as she was on the day she
sank 30 ft wide and almost 100 ft long
she's larger than a tennis court
capable of carrying over 200 tons of
cargo we have other questions so we have
to investigate inside of the
shre so little remains of the
ship Carlos must look to the cargo to
learn
more the team raises some of the jars to
the
[Music]
surface each weighs nearly 140
lb on land they're handled delicately
and examined in minute
[Music]
detail we start to discover some pottery
fragments that had a a waterproof resin
inside waterproof resin is a key clue it
means the Amor carried
liquid and in some of them ancient
sediment from that liquid reveals
something
else
Fishbones the amfor carry one of the
most popular products of the Roman
economy the superfood of the ancient
world fish
sauce known as garam
well garum or fish sauce is basically a
condiment that you would add to food to
enhance its flavor as you would today as
you would do with soy sauce or something
like
that and that's because Roman food
really was a bit
Bland and this is before they had
tomatoes before they had pizza before
they had you know the things we think of
in terms of Italian
food so the B fer was carrying fish
sauce but where had it come from
[Music]
the shape of the amfor gives Carlos a
clue we knew that that kind of anforas
are related to the Fisheries from the
south of
[Music]
Spain but where was the B ferer taking
them returning to the drained
wreck and removing layers of the amfor
reveals further
Evidence a secret cargo hidden for
centuries on either side of the Keel
strange metal
[Music]
ingots the team prizes 22 of them from
the wreck
[Music]
each weighs 140
lb in the laboratory careful examination
of the ingots reveals something
unexpected
the hidden cargo is not gold or
silver it's
lead and there's something
else all the ingots found on B forer are
stamped with the letters
IM it's the mark of the imperator the
Latin word for emperor
those marks are telling us that this uh
ingots belongs to the emperor and that
was like
wow that was just the moment where the
buerer change from such a large big
Roman vessel to something absolutely
different a vessel that has been able to
link in the story of Rome the bow for a
isn't just another cargo ship it's
taking at least a ton of metal to the
most powerful man in the
world so which emperor could it be
destined for and why does he need a
boatload of
[Music]
lead off the coast of Spain a remarkable
Roman shipwreck called the bow forer
conceals a secret C
go a fortune in Le possibly destined for
the emperor of Rome
[Music]
himself the drained wreck holds clues
that could reveal which
emperor hidden among the afor are two
weathered
[Music]
coins
the coins are made of
bronze on one side a faint
image almost invisible marks prove the
coins were stamped around ad.
66 during the reign of one of the most
infamous Emperors of them
all
Nero
[Music]
the information from the coins allows
Carlos to do something even more
remarkable date the sinking of the bow
for rare to the time of one of Rome's
greatest
disasters in 64 ad an inferno ravages
the city for 6
days according according to Legend Nero
plays his fiddle while his Capital
Burns whether that's true or not the
huge damage gives him the chance to
rebuild the city in his own
image The Great Fire of Rome destroyed
about two-thirds of the city and there
was a massive rebuilding campaign in the
years that followed and they obviously
needed the raw materials to do that lead
was a very important part of
that lead lines pipes in all kinds of
Roman Plumbing like the luxurious
bathouses enjoyed by the wealthy
Elite Carlos believes the emperor's Mark
is evidence that this cargo is destined
for Nero's very own
Palace the lavish domus
Arya the golden
[Music]
house this means the inot belong to Nero
himself and the bow ferer is sailing for
pis so she likely sinks before Nero's
death in 68
[Music]
ad but there's one final
question why did the bo fer and her
Imperial cargo fail to make it to
pis the drained wreck offers some
Clues the amfor are off
center they've shifted towards the port
side such a heavy cargo would never be
loaded like
this so what could cause some 5,000 m to
move
Carlos believes that the bow for a runs
into a
storm a large wave strikes the
hull causing the cargo to shift and the
vessel to list to her port
side making her impossible to
steer and allowing more waves to come
over her decks and slowly fill her
hold and then you are done it's a matter
of time maybe 20 minutes maybe 1 hour
bir you had
[Music]
done as Rome Masters the Seas ships like
Bo ferer are the Empire's lifeblood
carrying precious metals slaves and
especially grain to and from pis and
harbors all across the
Mediterranean spreading the power and
influence of
Rome including a strategic base in
modern-day Israel what the Romans called
Judea its capital cesaria maritima
stands at the crossroads of Africa and
Asia to the Romans it's the gateway to
the riches of the East an important
source of grain and exotic
spices transporting these Treasures to
Rome requires a
harbor but there are major
problems no natural inlets protect from
waves a Sandy Coastline offers no solid
footing for building and there's a
constant threat of
[Music]
earthquakes but according to historical
records two decades before the birth of
Jesus Roman Engineers defy nature
here they construct a grand offshore
Harbor transforming cesaria into a
wealthy trade
Hub it's a remarkable feat of
engineering yet today it's nowhere to be
seen
[Music]
for decades investigators like National
Geographic Explorer Beverly Goodman have
been trying to find
evidence we have a pretty good idea of
what the harbor might have looked like
because the historian flavus Josephus
left us a
record the entrance of the harbor had
towers and
statues you can kind of picture it being
this monumental Harbor comparable to
something you would see in
Rome but over the centuries the harbor
disappears only traces of this great
Roman Outpost remain scattered on dry
land as for what's left of the harbor
itself the focus of Beverly's
investigation must be
offshore
what she finds underwater is promising
but far from
Clear there's a lot of uncertainty about
which parts of the harbor are natural
and which of them are the artificial
features there are shapes that could be
natural or
man-made meticulous investigation
reveals they're resting on
Sand there's no natural B Redrock
underneath it's a sure sign they're all
man-made and could be part of the Lost
Harbor everything that you look at you
realize it was put there it was placed
there and so then you start to think
about that you start to really
understand the scale of of what this
place was
like to work out the size and
orientation of the ancient Harbor the
team must first create a comprehensive
sonar map of the
[Music]
seafloor so this kind of survey is
getting our Baseline Maps our basic
information that from that we can go and
find
Targets combining years of diving
surveys with these latest scans it's
possible to drain the waters from the
Eastern
Mediterranean and expose what's left of
the ancient Harbor of C ceria
maritima for the first time in almost
2,000
years as the water recedes it lays be a
strangely shaped structure on the
seafloor this long Jagged mass of rock
resembling a natural Reef stretches into
the empty
Basin opposite another wider Mass
reaches out almost a third of a
mile these are the remains of the
breakwaters of a massive Port that Spann
over 40
acres the harbor of cesaria
maritima so how did the Romans build
something so Monumental on nothing more
than
[Music]
sand
over 2,000 years ago in Judea Romans
perform an engineering Miracle at a
place called cesaria
maritima they construct the largest
artificial Harbor in the ancient
world revealed for the first time in
centuries the foundation of the huge
Harbor walls had to be built on shifting
sand it seems an impossible
task Beverly Goodman has come to the
site of the ancient Harbor to take
samples from its underwater
Remains the team inserts a pipe deep
into the
seafloor
to draw up traces from the
past so we managed to get a Core in very
deep next step is to open it see what we
have inside see what surprises wait for
us oh good all right we got quite a few
changes we need to need to log here and
take a look
at wow this is kind of surprising I
didn't think it was going to have quite
so much
variation on the upper part of the core
we have this natural sediment we really
have this period where the site is
nearly abandoned for many many
years then as we go down the core and we
start to get periods where there's
actually people around we start to see
more Pottery we start to see uh Rubble
we start to see changes that relate to
the fact that people were there and they
were influencing the environment they
were
building a sediment layer from the time
of the harbor reveals a
clue the rubble contains an unusual
mineral a particular type of volcanic
ash called
pelana it's not natural to this region
the source is over a th000 miles to the
West the slopes of Mount Theus in
Italy why bring pelana all this
way the reason still lies on the
seafloor of cesaria
maritima traces of a revolutionary Roman
invention
a new kind of
concrete we can actually see those
elements of the concrete and know that
this is the fingerprint of the presence
of the
Romans historical records reveal that
Roman Engineers FY tons of posala to
cesaria to imagine that they are
shipping across the Mediterranean 2,000
years ago you know essentially barges
that have volcanic ash coming from Italy
all the way across the Mediterranean to
the Eastern Mediterranean is really
something
phenomenal the Romans use concrete to
build on land throughout their
empire but then they realize that by
adding the posala ash to their concrete
mix they can use it underwater
too they're bringing this volcanic ash
in they're mixing it with the stone
rubble and the lime to create concrete
but it only hardens when you pour water
on it so if you take it into the sea
once it hits the water it
hardens it's known as hydraulic concrete
and it's a huge milestone in the history
of
construction for years how the Romans us
this modern building material to create
this
Harbor remains a
mystery but finds on the seabed provide
a
clue so one of the findings in cesaria
is preserved wood wood from 2,000 years
ago that was used to create the
framework for them to pour the concrete
to create these large structures of the
harbor 2,000 years ago the Romans work
with concrete just like we do
today they build wooden structures known
as queson that hold liquid Concrete in
place and then drop them into the
sea flooded with seawater the mixture
solidifies creating solid concrete
blocks man-made Bedrock on which to
build the first artificial Harbor in the
world we now know how ceria maritima was
constructed but there's one mystery
left contemporary accounts suggest the
harbor
disappears barely a century after its
[Music]
construction among the drained ruins
there's a clue to what
happened all the elements of the harbor
still remain but but they lie shattered
on the sea
Flor so what might have led to the
collapse of the
[Music]
harbor in the core samples layers of
sediment from after the construction of
the harbor help build a picture of
events when we find these layers and
when we see it's not like the deposits
that are above or below it so we can see
that it's in fact uh an isolated
incident these layers suggest that
something cataclysmic churned up the
sediment there is a reference that talks
about a possible tsunami in the year 115
ad maybe that's the event maybe not it
does coincide nicely with the finds that
we have and the ages that we
see it seems likely that this great
artificial Harbor is reduced to a
fraction of its former glory just as
Rome tightens its grip on the
Mediterranean world but caesaria part in
the history of the Roman Empire is not
over the Romans apply the power of their
wondrous concrete everywhere
establishing pts and harbors across the
Mediterranean wherever they
need this is the first and last time the
Mediterranean was under the control of
one power it wasn't a space where wars
were fought it was a place where trade
took place and that's why the Romans
have this kind of relationship with the
sea it's our sea Marin
[Music]
norstrom a thousand years will pass
before other nations Portugal and Spain
come close to matching what the Romans
achieve domination of the known world
through an Empire of the
[Music]
Seas